[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to another day
okay so it's playful charity streams
we're joined by some very special guests
today and I don't just mean Portillo oh
he's you know none of it ramen looks a
little bit more excited than coconut
cocoa couldn't have less of a [ __ ] loud
in here so he's like I have been free
please don't pee yeah sotae joining it
tomorrow myself
we've got gab Murphy and Dan your people
from rkg hello thank you so much for
joining us lads what are we doing today
so we're gonna be playing geoguessr and
if you've never played this it's
educational the don't switch off and on
case we're gonna be dropped somewhere in
the world on Google Street View and we
have to identify using nothing but our
eyes and knowledge where we are in the
world it's like pin the tail on the
donkey and the donkey sing like we yeah
we used to work at IGN we used to get
free video games but then when we left
they stopped sending them to us so we've
got to make our own fun on our Channel
yeah we do you get you get you get five
for free though you get five in a
standing order with the company card so
we're not gonna get timed out yeah yeah
you you introduced me and tan to this
how did you find it I'm through a little
man called Simon cardi what he watch his
own speed runs of it oh I saw it video
Friday and today but that click on a few
weeks ago if you haven't been watching
speedruns
thing is that now that my because I
obviously chat to you lives a lot I get
targeted YouTube algorithm speedruns of
geoguessr to serve his employment Proust
up pro level before he gets tired
where'd where do we want to drop do we
want to do like a world start for famous
places I'm also gonna portela back in
the kitchen because he can smell the
peanut butter and jelly sandwich I've
just had I keep going yeah well Lucy
takes care of Priscilla I'll just
quickly say that we are raising money
for to engage Lee important causes you
can see the links on the screen there
also in the YouTube description I know
that we have Ritchie watching and
moderating the chat and he'll drop it in
every now and then so there are two
causes are black lives matter which you
can donate to using bit or L wire for
that GS - BLM and then Direct Relief
which is supporting covered relief
efforts for frontline workers which is
bit ly for SS yes - co vid and please
donate generously if you can if you
can't you know just spread the word and
get people watching and send the links
to them as well and I will also keeping
an eye on chat so we'll kind of
occasionally look to chat to see if we
can get some advice on where we are
people already saying that we should be
me and you give or give a and Gatsby
they can't tell us apart
well lots of we've talking about this
before we started but like we we don't
you for a while and like lots of people
do mistake us I used when you were over
in the UK like they used to mistake us
for each other at events and stuff like
that your phone things were the same
person yeah my mum thinks we're the same
person sometimes yeah tom was actually
like the first person I ever met
on my very first day in my very first
games job as well like that time do you
know do you remember that yeah it was
the lift right like is the lifts man
yeah do you remember what do you
remember you said to me you look me dead
in the eyes are you saying you you ain't
[ __ ] you ain't never gonna be [ __ ]
and then punch me in the stomach as hard
as you could I'm from then like I knew
you know you're keeping me you keep
grounded that's what I like about it and
now and again when I see you we'll just
come over to me and punch me in the
stomach it's a reminder that evening
yeah anchored in the yeah keeps me
humble keeps me humble so we do famous
places okay let's see use ourselves in
yeah let's not do desert yes yeah
Oh challenge incredibly we haven't even
started we already got a $20 donation
from James J Armstrong for black Thank
You Jay Johnson's a legend man Thank You
Man
hero what is your merica so Skydeck is
that oh wait I've been well this is New
York right Willis uh-huh oh is this um
Skydeck is the oh no it's your discord
really artifact Edoras oh yeah magic I
into something people Lane it's either
top of the I feel like it's the
Rockefeller Center
what was Willis Willis Tower Sears Tower
Lego architecture think this is made of
Lego of this I'll tell you word for it
so I can see here no ID looks like the
Sears Tower sauce Chicago yeah I was
gonna say Sears Tower
seems like it's it does kind of look
you've got find Chicago on the east
plate it Lakes yeah oh god don't tell
Greg I just asked why Chicago was yeah
we've got we've already got a little lad
Simon cardi in the chat who says five
meters or bust
that's easier you're so what cardi is
referring to is we need to try and get
it five meters on left yeah oh yeah are
we thinking this is that she's just in
the bottom of the building if so we've
got a pretty good shot that's what it is
yeah this is definitely just in the
basement yeah basement ground floor
basement look Portillo's hot dogs ice
here that's you know what his name is it
like is it actually the dog is named
after a hot dog yeah yeah actually and
like honestly fun fun side story about
me when I was that took me to the the
Sunderland Air Show and I'm picky eater
as a child and my dad got me a hamburger
it was a hamburger made of hot dog meat
and it was the single worst than ever
eaten in my life
oh my god made me eat half of it because
obviously he had to remortgage the house
to pay for it and then because they were
so bloody expensive and so for years I
didn't eat hot dogs I thought they were
disgusting Greg had got a delivery of
Portillo's hot dogs and I had one and it
was like II feel like ever see ever
since you've moved to America your
Instagram food game like the stuff that
you're eat then is pretty good and I'm
pretty impressed with her because I live
with them and slightly annoyed I'm
slightly annoyed you haven't put on
lately loads more weight though because
if I was living there I would be massive
massive ah more massive that's why I've
been doing like I've been slowly
becoming like a wobbly plate of jelly
over time this this is Willis Tower is
that the same as Ian power I think C is
like the sponsored the Sports Direct
Stadium right so I'm not sure boss
what's director a sitcom at st. James's
Park
there's the entrance it's it's
definitely this music it's a gift
yeah that's a little cat way there yeah
that would be like ground floor in it so
this is a little like more groups of
people inside like other shops and
things okay unless this is the Boston
Museum of skyscrapers Oh
all Legoland by Lego long before all
this stuff says Chicago so yeah yeah I
think it's the Sears Tower
should we just plunk it right here then
we just he can say Chicago and this a
sign that says hot dogs as well so all
right there yeah we get inside there
yeah yeah
is there a little Google symbolist it's
like a photo inside yeah what on this
yeah
I can't move around here yeah I was
there no movement I think that's on the
photo switches dream of any screenshot
[Laughter]
that immediately
she's clipping it out for her own gram
you create well she's clipping Benno
Thomas who donated $25 to black lives
matter and also J Armstrong did another
one for directly twenty dollars in honor
of the rkg boys and also Daniel Gomez
twenty dollars oh don't see any go man
the Arcadia community Papaji Ramirez you
got donate yeah okay I'll give $10 for
each zero Mears oh really yeah not you
how much all right
also I would say I hope all the other
ones we'd get drops in places that have
the name of the place in the picture
yeah that always helps I think for in
Eastern Europe it never feels like a
good bet
that's pretty Catholic to me we can move
around on this one
oh wait there's a signpost over here
let's go Ukraine even your motherland
groups imagine if we'd land edition your
mother lead yeah they like a church they
love the church and tell you that okay
so this is a lot of rubbish on here yeah
clean up in your own country with
rubbish collection service he bastards
is this France
Rudy Cardinal we bear I mean it what
other french-speaking countries are
there though it could be key like Canada
somewhere infringing an eighteen I
didn't see that we Rudy Cardinal new IDE
RT and then this is famous places so
yeah what's the famous that's not soccer
career but from the other side well
marked Montmarte
is that round there no it's next
okay yeah you can get you seen yeah wait
Oh can we see any other person can we
see the Eiffel Tower
okay I'll get to hurry you go I I've
missed the front of it again yeah the
sacre-coeur does it go little doe me top
thus it does yeah that's the sacre-coeur
sorry I'm just I'm wait infinitive catch
up on the actual YouTube so I can see it
where's oh that's a good shot it'll be
clear on YouTube on it yeah that's what
I'm watching and wait for me I've hidden
it I've hidden the chat okay oh yeah
here so we are this is the corner so we
should here return to stop so we're just
off to the left and I think what's done
just on the street have you going back
to the beginning yeah yeah the beginning
so we're just off the side I think like
yeah Romans over that time these are the
these are the two streets that were
intercepting and then we are about yeah
just off to the left a little bit this
is good loose this is good it's good
idea alright if we get but if we get a
bang all nonstic 20 I'm trying to
remember we always think are like in the
right place and it's always like to the
left and down a bit find about the
naught meters is because geoguessr often
yeah you think you're bang on you no
one's about you know set in London and
we know exactly where it is in exactly
right and it says oh no you're actually
five meters up in this direction so yeah
this yeah I think I'm good a few guys
are yeah yeah yeah yeah
no there it is five meters it did it I
literally looked at the floor and it
said that we were we were on the road of
Cooper and oh no you still get the five
grand you still get the five grand for
it
but that's fine yet Jay Armstrong says
geoguessr Zarkon at times all right all
right yeah so that's a good one we're
close well I'm guessing we're in Aris
tapas are so it hasn't loaded properly
for me so just say it looks like it says
pasta bizarre yeah to go to there you
can't move on this one
what's that flag yeah wha
Connie or the language of the street
signs yes besides like Persian but like
in I mean I was gonna say imprecise
fairly frequently used as like Turkey so
this is like um it's famous places right
yeah probably it's damn bull yeah when
you start making your own games on the
internet like I don't think I don't
think the geoguessr was made to be used
like this
where's like if you want to do a
PlayStation game easy they know they
know it's only know where you can whack
it into all manner of devices and get
the gameplay out from it but not for
geoguessr when are they do get on
consoles put poor me here get the spring
and it's cluesive ps5 announced that
game over boys yeah where's the Jeff
Kiwi announcement inside final days yeah
okay I'm trying to read to find it
debated all the turkey yeah yeah it's
the eros arasta ARS now you could go for
a little it depends mother which one I
like putting me down and have a go or
try and find another clue yeah yeah
let's try find another clue but I don't
think we
can't move on this one I like movin this
is low res even on my screen is unit
yeah yeah well I just thinking like oh
we we just been Cillian is it the era
stuber's are because I know like Grand
Bazaar is an actual tourist location
right yeah yeah super close in to see if
we cheer gets a battle royale someone
says yeah like I'm relatively certain
it's in Istanbul so if we can find
Istanbul so we're on Istanbul right now
oh okay big it's just very big I'm also
not it's a big bazaar how far it goes
yeah it's also weird because depending
on the level of zoom zoom
super close into the actual Istanbul
text and maybe we'll find it there nikon
d I can let's go 1 2 1 let's drop in
though walkabout yeah oh no this is
basically how we've been traveling
around cuz we miss travelling so yeah
right would be nice to go there
I'd it to me loose maybe maybe just like
start a bit coat and then your city
breaks although I I do kind of feel like
the more that the lockdown goes on I
keep saying I'm gonna do more and more
stuff and I feel like it'd be like oh
now you can do all the stuff you like
how probably just carry on doing nothing
actually human quality there's a big
department store here
Oh bizarre okay there's a bizarre here
but it's uh Tyree he I'm yeah it's it's
not
so at least at least we know the bazaars
are the blue little ones with the
shopping bags yeah I think we need to go
out a bit I can't i-i've lost track of
where we are I'm tempted just to drop a
pin somewhere like you've gone that way
times gone the other way like no we will
zoom right right into their coast area
[Music]
near the bridge kind of cause like I
don't like is like they have loads of
bazaars in in like they will yeah one of
the things they're known for we do
bazaars naturally flock bridges bridges
needs to be near the coast to get get
you product in the spices dye is true
that is true mean is actually true yeah
yeah you cannot bazaar anywhere now
you've got Tesco's in our state park
Tesco is not as bizarre saffron cafe
near
I say if we're gonna if we're gonna just
bang it anywhere nice bang it on the
bang on the coast good this you know
just close enough but it's not
I reckon I reckon like on the coast near
the nearly like the Istanbul text
okay which vanished like right about
here then hold on let me let the twitch
catch up so this simple text is here
yeah like that
maybe like in that collection of yellow
buildings okay because we've got a
decent chance of it being one of those
yeah yeah all right okay ooh two yards
okay those pretty goods that's not bad
I for those gonna be a [ __ ] show I went
a bit Quags I couldn't see anything
outside no way no way bus
nice fantastic that's is that the sage
yes oh I thought that's where we saw a
Bunsen throat no maybe it's not I'm Mike
no that looks like it's RFI now no
thanks I kind of Barbican yeah yeah I
think that is you know it might be there
will be blood in like basically a
theater that looks exactly the same as
that yeah the Barbican stuff does
looking for me I guess like theater
people probably just go well that one's
really good let's just copy that it's
like let's not go rogue here this is the
Sydney Opera House everybody loves that
I use its property I love it if we went
outside and you've seen Sydney Harbour
Bridge um yeah definitely castle far
away from the studio is it's the
Playhouse where it's the one with the
funny roof loose which why this is gonna
sound stupid which way we face in which
one my always stays resting I think I
think red is boy I think we're facing
south so from the Batman yeah someone
someone said this is the hit memory
tutorial level it might be that one I
think it's this one because we're facing
south mmm yeah cuz like there are big
I'm looking into this too much or maybe
the drama Sarah hmm I mean either way
let's just put it in the middle be
closed
yeah BA in chat says the sage building
in Newcastle for rkg fans is
affectionately known locally as the
slugs change all right in the middle
yeah go for it oh all right it's all
right
almost five grand an hour does the sage
building does look a bit like a slug you
wonder why wait let's check it like not
like a lot like before we've been dumped
right Cardiff Wales ooh the number 12
quick quick shower well dunk here thank
you very much man
absolute legend I've been in that Tesco
Express many times it's a western sky
it's like this is where we stood by us
Westminster Bridge isn't it yeah yeah
now the um Tom and Lucy now that you've
been in in America for so long what's
like the crapless thing that you miss
mate do you know I was I said this the
other day and I can't remember who was
talked to I think it was cardi and and
might Lucy was there but they they
respond what call irresponsive responded
with this is the saddest thing I've ever
heard
the other day I went on YouTube and just
search for Leytonstone and then I
watched a man just doing a walk down my
old home where I used to more well my
family as well he like flip the camera
around to say something and I was like
I've seen him on the streets like I know
this guy and he like walking near my
houses world I bought it like longingly
looked down into my Road thing is that
you fix the camera you like I've seen
that guy then you just realize like
you've you've watched that video like 50
times that you've already been there
like but you've always been here
[Laughter]
it was good though because he had like
knowledge about the area that I had
never knew like he was like oh this is
the school and it wasn't the school I
went to as a kid and when our damon
albarn
oh so straight on it's pretty much on
the corner yeah little bit of a gap are
we not on this
well it says yeah yeah that's good all
right our weekend
Lutie when you press some submit you say
that distance yeah as a piss-take is
road do you guess I don't think you're
even allowed in though there's a fence
yeah sort out just just as a roll pass
in the middle of the road each time the
thing is clearly like Walt that's pretty
good
for five guests 24900 M smudge hey
that's good so that's that's that's what
we got to be okay that's gonna be
[ __ ] hard yeah oh that's radom well
while we figure out what we want to do
next - Ramona - there's two donation
links on the screen and in the chat
please try and give as much as you can
all funds raised go directly to black
and kovaydin nineteen relief efforts
with direct police scene as you seen as
you guys are missing London should we go
London and then and then we'll go wider
we were great London we did that
recently we just read in London it was
like every single one of them was like
zone II that's okay I'll just do
Midlands hey reckons if I leave and then
rejoin the call it might improve so one
second is that risky business I'm
watching on twitch and that's helpful
okay
London moderate oh I didn't realize it
has like a nice little explanation
London was founded as a communication
sensor by the Romans shortly after they
invaded Britain in 43 ad the conclusion
remains the same what perfect binding of
the past and the present is [ __ ] with
so many places to pray said that one
couldn't find the time to chat Egypt as
well don't worry about it
grows no hole oh this is the de cruz
grove the whole street this can you go
back up the other way do the direction
this is gonna be one of those situations
where it's literally one of our
workplaces again well he's got back the
other way i just wanna check something
all right which way so yeah i keep going
though yeah keep going keep going
oh my god that's where it's at ramen -
oh whoops class it definitely is
that's where ramen went to puppy school
absences so this is near what's on
Victoria line after Pimlico before like
st. James mill by there Oh way Brixton
Pimlico bricks Wow I'll stock well no
before that so it's north of the war
it's New Westminster what's the cheap
line on there north of Pimlico Victoria
what else is under so let me think back
to when I worked in the Victoria Line
its Brixton as at the bottom then a
stock well Vauxhall yeah in James Park
in James Park yeah
it's st. James pirates the court that's
the to stop I used to get off with
rather oh so okay see look I know you're
looking for a prat oh man prayer oh he's
the Pratt prime manager past that mm-hmm
oh there's another present here too
bollocks
is a prayer everywhere boo there's also
the Embassy of Macedonia so that is the
closest to stop okay okay I think it's
more northeast of the tube stop poking a
hole so he means the other prayer which
might be the one
okay looks like a five minute it's like
a five minute walk from the tube station
it's north northeast or east first year
what if i zoom in again
[Music]
Oh pals for pets is that where he went
no it's just like that Grover the whole
shy community said no I think that's all
they are
puppy district in private not in private
you boarded him you bored in your puppy
so we're looking for Vincent Street okay
oh there's another prayer how many
buddypress are in this area they're
taking over my Scott versus us in the
YouTube chat what's your favorite prayer
sandwich
good question there Christmas forget you
forget so good so good the standard
ploughman's for me Oh classic classic
British classic great British classic
solver a French eatery I don't think it
is st. Joe's cuz that's not on the
Victoria Line I must be going ahead
Oh st. James's Park is I believe on the
Victoria Line yeah is it no no Victoria
no line st. James's Park is under there
Oh : my bad I was getting I was getting
off at putting The Cove and I Pimlico is
a station on the Victor line to st.
James's Park yeah here's a prat
we're looking for was it Vincent Street
Marsha man Vincent yeah
here we go here we go oh that prop go
back I got it that Vauxhall Bridge Road
that's the big yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah put it in somewhere awkward little
to the right yeah and like furtherance
lightly feather in here away from the
room I always think on the road go in
there because I'm willing to defer it
it's not off on the road he's got more
time in Jerusalem me so you know I don't
know I don't know no I'm not I'm not
saying i'm not i'm not taking blame for
nobody wants to say this is your blog
thing or whatever is what is worse
GameSpot
[Laughter]
I'm good it's all about five grand
it's all about the five minutes hello
chicken someone's gonna be they doing a
selfie stick
classic dang am i walking down the Danny
and I walking down the street the other
day and we saw a man with a giant parrot
on his UFC OC in that massive parallel
you we were like we just stopped but
he's an emu he still you know even if we
go via the success that we had last time
it's gotta be directly on the point it's
one side than the other real quickly
okay Matt Hawking gave us $10 for
I said let me know when you find in San
Diego and nice no Isaac ball who's been
donating so much so it almost every yeah
and then anonymous $50 for directly sent
thanks for supporting an important cause
and then anonymous me an anonymous in
the show yeah
expect us on geoguessr and marsala also
donated yesterday and I think as Austria
and did $20 for Derick relief so just
shower for both of those thank you so
much the links are on the screen if you
want to donate all going towards thank
you okay I'm I'm just gonna hit it hit
it and quit it
[Laughter]
that was 89 years away that was - think
it's one rule for one mode yeah rules
for another mode it's fine
we will don't I don't know if you can
blame to yoga necessarily but I ooh well
we're a French Connection let's go that
is what war Duke Street that is the
Henry Holland pub I'm G oh I thought you
knew it Selfridge is this is it
Selfridges yeah or at least I think it's
the song I would yeah are we just behind
Oscars really main self-interest how can
we travel to have a look yeah we can if
he yeah this is off ox history yeah
God was this taken in the Hakeem's
Street now yeah we're not going right
yeah oh and then we were on what jig
Street on nanos Oh kinky
what's the finding it out you got cheap
Nando's now it's nothing what's up no
it's me what's it yeah I mean I can't
take advantage of it literally you know
in a country with Oh
Selfridges news about reopening ten
stores here I'm more near Marble Arch
we've had a donation from twenty five
dollars from the lad on the bridge wild
maybe maybe anonymous told him but I
always it always a Duke Street wasn't it
so where's Henry Holland's
so I think we're about like you okay
see how Henry Owens there we're facing
that terrifyingly says the new order
let's go
and then this is the first French
Charles French Connection shut down I
don't believe there's a French
Connection there anymore
yeah once I poured it up yeah
this is muff you've really old then do
that
yeah so that's so that might not appear
on the map so I think we're about here
now it's quite close to the median
Oxford Street yeah yeah oops isn't yeah
yeah so weird
that's pretty good you're quite close to
the edge yeah what's up story points it
to the middle I don't think but I think
we're like slightly closer to Oxford
Street
okay five grand five grand
that's pretty good
I could mess up a Krispy Kreme over
seeing that in absolutely that's bull
yes not I just saw you come up on Twitch
where we asked lie oh right having a
quick smoke break in this corner family
Warren Vine Street oh is that the angel
yes do pubs can we just two pups
oh that's near my gen that's the
pregnant thats the pret near all gauged
oh we got past that prayer I may ask you
man
it's near an ass your ground station
near all-gay east Fenchurch Street it's
neither mine see if you can if you can't
go down that Street past that Starbucks
do you show everyone where I Jenna's
yeah yeah I mean I think the addresses
on the websites I think okay we're
technically not dachshund idea
what is bad people that you can walk
straight up without having to tap on any
security things that's bad shouldn't say
that but the address is on the website
so it's fine we don't worry about no
where are my so if you go to you if you
got a Tower of London your Fenchurch
Street just kind of noise west of that
yeah okay vine streets and cross wall
there's the prayer so we're in this this
[Music]
hmm side street yeah the prayer is on so
we are here weather geoguessr says that
we are definitely there I feel like
we're trying to predict how it's gonna
screw us over here it will put us across
the road on that corner guaranteed I
want a 1 a 5 grand this will be 5 grand
okay but it's the weather it's a zero
yeah we were spoiled by getting zero on
the first space in it yeah they
certainly sent him out that you
discovered Mars straight away and
there's like guys no but no point now
yeah I can land this thing yeah just
doing skids on the moon is my heart
explode
Oh coming back Oh God
it's a Moscow yeah he gets back his wife
is already shacked up with a poodle as I
didn't think you were coming back NASA
told me you'd be dead so now I am king
of you people for me is really exposed
my Pratt knowledge yeah all right so
where's the prey in this one yeah only
run oh the Beehive pub no I was gonna
say that but it actually looks like it
was a pub slash restaurant is that
closed down hmm
we've got a couple of donations Oh what
is it hundred dollars from Sam Smith
which is Ricky
our very own Sam Smith friend of us was
a friend of the show and of the show a
friend of ours
Sam Smith if it isn't chard Sam either
way and then Kieran Marshall donated $10
thank you so much it's thank you very
much Kieran and Sam did did was it
called the bomb song is out the same one
yeah yeah is he in - in the brute under
pretty way yeah they're all the same
awesome ants are the same it's like Jet
Li's the one they just exist in postcode
homeless treat elbows go on w1 tell me
Chelsea shall we to be warmer
yeah Crawford Street
this looks like this could be a bit of a
main road down here yeah I can't go that
way
tell me one is like near read history
ain't it right Crawford there was a crew
Fisher will be very smart phone as well
I'm on the phone yeah alright so home
mystery Crawford Street the Larrick
I think the lyric was in Marylebone you
know yeah it is this is what this is
Marvin this is where we used to work man
yeah yeah so seen you should learn about
me is that I'm really really bad with
geography so where we will be we'll be
closer to Edgware Road than Paddington
yeah the edgeware Road will be really
close yeah I can see here's Kensington
where's it from Kinzie Paddington's up
here you go if you go to Paddington and
then go first a little bit that was the
marmalade little boy yes yes so if you
go to I reckon if you go to Edgware Road
will be closer to that because the
Larrick is I'm pretty sure that's one of
the posh pubs we used to do leaving
drinks from if it's the one I'm thinking
of it's really close to a casino hasn't
been in a casino too many times
yeah I'm by Edgware Road right now so I
yeah someone's describe me as a job old
gal what's that
oh what a job oh god oh god
no wait
I'm Tam you go that road we sure it's
not closer to ya so go Edgware Road
that's the thing I'm confused about
where we actually need to go now
[Music]
Crawford Street Crawford is a biggie so
they say the Beehive there's a become
there's something called Delta I
honestly I remember it being really
close to like edge railroad station
because I remember going there a few
times and having to bounce after so
having to lean I'm not around I remember
the walk not being that long okay so we
saw on Houma Street they I don't believe
the Beehive was here oh it's a XM London
and it's a phantom London on the
makes em London's there hello it's a
town googleman yeah so we are actually
about diamond locations inca why they
like for bloody churches here oh you got
a problem with Ivan so many churches
American a lousy grow the only one no
you said like first a bit like yeah you
might want to stop it with all that
sometimes these three come on we can get
this actually yeah assuming okay like
[Music]
exams they're right behind it say yay
yeah I think that was just so things I
think that's looking good honestly
let's do it yeah kind of good six meters
we got the five grand oh well it's done
this thing again that it does sometimes
it assumes you all the way our and it is
evil way yeah also sometimes I feel like
with geoguessr when you're in the city
is a bit more of a pain in the ass with
the meters you know that's this this
what we gotta live with every day
so twenty five five eight thousand five
hundred you that's what we got yeah oh
it's less than one week off first time
but then we did a little bridge hey
don't worry about it anyway let's not
talk no one was even thinking about it
no one no one was thinking about it no
one was taxing me under the table about
it like
that was happening don't worry about me
why you seem on the Chia where we think
it actually before we say witness I'm
still run for a quickly a minute and
just so you know I'm not wearing any
trousers so if you see anything please
donate because you paid this is an only
fan stream now we can we cut to the wide
let's go to the wide world Cavs taking a
Kevin gold has done it at $10 the black
less man thank you so much Kevin
while Garvey's empty in the dragon it's
just recap on the fundraising effort
we're raising money for black lives
matter and you can see the link on the
screen
oh I forged last year's - BLM and then
Direct Relief
Bioforce last year - co vid please
donate generously if you can all
proceeds are going directly to those
causes games games boy who's not taking
anything out that we also have their
GameSpot store so if you want to buy
something instead you can go to store
Gamescom there's a bunch of really cool
things in there there's a t-shirt as a
pity there's a face mask a skate deck a
poster touch tool so you don't have to
touch anything with your hands and get
grubby all colored stuff on it it's all
low-key really subtle stuff that looks
nice and anything just anything you buy
from there the proceeds are split 50-50
between Direct Relief and black lives
matter and all proceeds from the going
directly to those charities until August
2020 so anything you buy up until that
point end of August will go to those
causes the posters really gonna do it
you've gotten really good at doing that
thank you I think me and Lucien like
repeating it non-stop can you keep on
doing after this is done yeah I'm just
gonna do that everybody up and
yeah so what we do next I've never done
the daily challenge before the challenge
in the chat as well for the next one so
what do you daily has any suggestions or
what we want to do then a taking a shot
is a good show if we open it wider to
the wider world because then we need
language knowledge is it in Saru if
anyone speaks I read so really that's a
great help
so chat if you want to suggest what we
want to do next please do so well do
what we could keep coming wider to the
next one we could just do United Kingdom
oh yeah then we might get a new castle
you might get unless unless Joe
scrabbles
popped on to I we once did I'm UK and
Joe was pretty good at Newcastle they
got I am South Shields oh hang on we
can't start without reading the little
blurb so the British Isles had been
inhabited for over 30,000 years and have
been involved in everything from the
Roman conquest to the British Invasion
also which won by also that is bad right
we've been involved in everything
who says we haven't yeah we we've been
invaded and we have it's been invaded
we've done the invading whoo we did it
all it's also supposed to child of fish
and chips pubs and the weather condition
commonly known as rain the United
Kingdom is the poster child of fish and
chips instead of the other way around
well
it's really just UK yeah every time
couple people in the twitch and YouTube
chat were like what is going on so we're
playing a game called gene yes where you
inputs you somewhere in your specified
region where Canada United Kingdom and
then you've got try and pinpoint as
close as you can to where you are
currently situated so in this one we are
in Southampton sick so they're so lovely
did you start wacky camera angle there
so st. Edmund's Road in the city of
Southampton
we could have a little wonder see if we
wanted to see or something of this
church what's he doing shifty what's the
house I should start watching the
documentary about the Golden State
killer killer yeah well I I watched the
second one yesterday and will gave
myself a home invasion nightmare so it's
real good like I when I was younger I
used to have way more nightmares and I
currently do and home invasion was
always the one and it was always I
wouldn't be holding the door never
closed genuinely I've said I've said
this on all this stuff
have you ever seen that episode of city
where they get house invaded it turns
out to be Matthew Wow
oh it's genuinely terrified was the
thing that scared me most is the kids
after study I Matthew fell out with them
- he ran away and then they thought they
were getting brought onto at night and
it turns out to be Matthew Bruce is
terrified Wow thank you it properly [ __ ]
me out that is a quick-fix
oh my god nope
all home set will come oh these are
actually really usable parts oh it's not
a Nero main shopping street it's good
this is where we say in Southampton
narrowed down to a city or anything so
we're in Southampton from a street side
David Lee in the chat says I've been in
quarantine so long that I would welcome
a home invasion just for a chat Park
Street Sounds big so maybe yeah paddy
power
shard - DPD quick fit in Wilkins I'm
also looking around around oh hang on
this looks like a big [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
Luce surely hi streets that must be near
the Shirley hotel this is incredible
knowledge Shirley kebab house so here's
a little fitting tribute
so we let's go back we're on so we she
was like a suffragette or something why
should we do tell they're anonymous
again and anonymous says I'm back though
who do you want me to hug
yeah so I think I think it's this corner
so Edmonds Road oh yeah this is going
into clarification on that see what
ultimately matters
yeah let's go for a little walk
tile and brick
where we stream this a few weeks back we
went on a massive walk until we found
sir we knew yeah
Cambridgeshire yeah we got yeah we got
so lost at one point I called up a
number that I saw on a side of a van it
looks like she's on ways to make a
donation to me if you see any phone
numbers I will phone them up for us
still this might be a stupid question
it's Cambridge the same thing as
Cambridgeshire no Cambridge up cake
Cambridge inside that Cambridge
Cambridgeshire yeah yeah
Oh sign there's a sign okay like a
county city vibe that's what the sign
says
Lucy's gonna have to zoom all the way in
for that she's like on tile goose campus
right so became a chef it'll be a little
Tory lad - you can steal these glasses
it's a little small
I know okay I know where so if not if
like if Norwich is there then Cambridge
is just that mean like you know I mean I
you know like the Norwich nub like the
rump of the UK yours yeah like if norine
Bridget like they're so creamy
yeah Cambridge is like the lower back
kidney yeah I went too far
no anything I don't think would yes
street names I'm gonna help us that is
when we need to guess like gotta be from
a county yeah okay we're gone we've got
phone number on those famines this is
like building they are not gonna be
based here are they
oh this is nice lookit I'm gliadin that
site not more like Norwich ways like
East Anglia yeah we need an umbrella
yellow think it's blood yeah I'll could
find a number we can ring I don't want
to be dark buckling drive a sir are we
allowed to Google a Granger
okay yes yeah Jess who the people at
home know what I'm doing is I'm just I'm
basically hovering around we're allowed
to go on Google Maps ourselves right but
we're not allowed to actually not to
search type anything in yeah yeah yeah
so I'm basically hanging around the
orange he's doing yeah this seems like a
bridge I think we we need a big name we
need a we need a Sudbury
we need a burry st. Edmund's ejup rat
bread just Pratt I let me know you know
so I I've only caught one or two with it
why buddy caught one or two of these
streams but like what have you been you
mean basically playing video games right
no they've had people kissing Cosima
Elden ring and they're like yeah we're
gonna be debut in some some sick
geoguessr gameplay slated on mine I mean
it's a Cambridgeshire we've never shown
anyone before people have been in the
area three we're the only ones to have
geoguessr on it so yeah exactly
DLC confirmed games for exclusive
have the idea this is the longest
straightest emptiest road yeah that's
okay that's okay it's not like all we
need to be long
all we need to do is hit we just need to
hit a big place Cambridgeshire but I
think all this angling stuff puts this
baby closest was that bit towards
Norwich because met we see more angling
stuff the only field Cambridgeshire
tiles see cuz I what I want to hit a
road so if we can hit the a11
I think we're somewhere around the a 11
if we can hit the a11 then I think we
can guide ourselves back Gavin a road
give a man a road we'll take a beer
obeyed me no honk I I just I so I'm
watching on a YouTube chat on our
YouTube channel no no what your YouTube
channel I've just seen Mina Hong said
this road actually looks like many roads
in America you wish pal you wish it's
one of the UK's roads it's uniquely UK
don't try and claim this house is rich
Harbor all the scribbled all over what's
going on it looks like that's how I'm
gonna do it I was like it's prime for a
pebble - destroyed this house the green
trim with that way I mean we're
definitely I hate this place why then no
signs
there's no pause go back to the
beginning I'm gone oh gosh
this is wrong see it we got a sign so
this is the only wise it would stuff I
went the other way and there was [ __ ]
all number on my van get me get me a
phone number Edmonson electrical don't
know any phone numbers no can't see it
have you ever done a job in Cambridge
it's thought I must have a takeaway or
some oh is number number yeah excellent
right so what what are they called
well building services okay
what's the net what's the phone number
read out to me cuz I can't see [ __ ] oh
one six three eight yeah sickly error 4
6 0 4 8 9 7 8 9 7 let me I got a ringer
I was gonna ask him where they are yeah
wait what did you say oh one six three
eight one six three eight six zero four
eight nine seven eight sixty or four 897
right okay for context 20 past 90 where
are you where where are you tell me you
are I've caught building and servicing
what are you wearing also okay yeah
okay I'll call them
someone's got a little boat in his back
garden ooh what's this and environmental
sunrise interstate sounds okay Shh
I mean they can't hear you Kevin
Burdette is the Vickery phone number
chunks
I'm not regular Church I will mean is
bun well but that's definitely Burwell
yes [ __ ] I'm just looking around now so
i'm i'm at i basically gone I've gone
I've gone to Cambridge
I'm just looking straight around there
or it could be the east of Cambridge
like with Anglia all the Anglia stuff
perhaps as borough is in Cambridgeshire
oh yeah we know that it is fun yes here
we go in there fantastic
so someone in chat said so EAD do I sing
bocha was no don't do it
Burwell Baptist Church is that it
probably is
okay so buh-bye Baptist Church please
toys lame oh this is superb um we're
gonna smash this not straight okay okay
can be done another 25 grand we want a
25 grand which is this one so we OB on
silver street are we on God knows now
cuz we store it on my country street
with the pylons then we honest I think
we're here right now so I think we came
oh hang on this is it then we come all
the way down here yeah a massive road
we've been going for ages yeah
well I think you'll be the road that
will be a bit more obvious I think it's
that big long strokes there's nothing on
it it's just the necks of high odds
isn't it yeah so wait Oh
so I remember seeing where did we go
Connor where do you go should we go back
to the yang
yes yeah yeah let's go pick it in and
then I reckon we'll be able to like tell
what road that is from the map like
nothing college is so oh wait hang on is
it this street
I'm also the like can we zoom in and we
might be able to see that came with your
tiles things we know that's right next
to the start cambridgeshire tile and
brick I can't go down there but it might
not be that this is a fairly slight road
isn't it it's about here in it or is it
wait I mean I could go I feel all the
way down here back and see if there's a
sign or what street it connects on to
yeah yeah so this is a random one-off
house let's not ring back yeah that
could show shows up on the map I'll be
quite useful residential and then here
we go here we go here we go here we go
Dyson's drove that meets Tyson strong
well here's here's a weird drugs
we're Joe and this is Dyson's allegedly
leading to something road.the begins an
S ya come see let me see where's there
another Street in the land of no Street
there might be some Cambridge people in
they saw out time what the hell why does
this place I've known bizarre Briarwood
is the name of that house that's the
thing there's no rules out in this part
of the country is there they just they
just do whatever they want
anyway but they don't have numbers on
the houses but place is called Briarwood
yeah one of them just said one of it one
of the houses just called apple trees
yes imagine being a postman in that
[Music]
do you find so much yeah I never thought
we'd be on them by Cambridgeshire I feel
I'll be faster it's trying to commit to
something I move on from this it's so
close though we've invested so much time
in this one yeah that's a thing will pop
committed now though right we need the
five grand if we're definitely sure on
the church if it is that church we can
just backtrack yes yeah it's a lot yes
we feel we happy
just go for it you know oh
Lydia's archery I can't quite see a way
because customerid whatever that road is
it's a very slight road isn't it yeah
yeah maps out he says Lucy scroll up a
bit on the map the tile and brick is
there whoa no rest of the map I mean
this Holland brick is critical if we can
find it this one yeah there we go
tell him brick is it because everything
to this situation little home went on to
Dyson's drove so we were just too far
ahead that mAbs labs a Lee NJ Armstrong
with an appetite
legends more north of the map that goes
out to jail
boom Misun are we still on course for
the 25,000 we've also got $10 from
Stephen what thank you yeah pebbles a
legend yeah all right
this is south of England is that well no
this could be well but you play in
[Laughter]
lights
Kynaston how you know Shelford Shalford
Road and once I really got two names
yeah why
trihard of a road Shalford Road
I can't see I'm waiting for the you
think the cash over there is feds
where is Beresford's in a state agent
thing is like if it's a surname
Beresford Danelle well as bare as James
burrows fit can we give her a ring ring
gave up its we need your help
Beresford stage yeah it could just be a
mad it could be everywhere yeah there is
a place so you know how I said earlier
that Newcastle in Australia is close to
Sydney we went there and we were gonna
take a picture of us at the sign and we
were at place called Beresford Street so
we sent it to our mate very cold words
no bowtie other story this is all
comfort pulsar I can't go dark
long ass someone in Charles is England
completely yeah very much yeah yeah it
did like flat earthers probably started
in England they were just like it Cisco
they were in a field just flash
apostrophe number oh one three seven six
or one three seven day would you want
the the estate agent if you got carbon
trees that look like he's that looks
like his mouth yeah let's get the mobile
that's more likely to be picked up than
an office oh seven eight nine oh seven
eight nine four fifty four fifty one
nine eight eight is for my that in a bad
way
yes well then it okay I don't know we
gonna bring up with him
it's nine thirty over there she's
calling she's calling bhai at home
don't have it
okay well we're in London see I gotta
put I gotta put their reg number in tax
if their cars tax if not I'll ring the
police tell them the cars not packed and
then we'll get them that way yeah coins
not accepted here you paying for that
okay I feel like out of the village now
this is hard this one yeah this is
really hard
you only invest in sign as much are you
do they write just I guess they probably
don't need to we don't know they know
everything
yeah no one's ever leaving one of these
towns anyways the way out sign we so we
I think what we need to do we we need to
get to a sign that says like you know
Oxford 20 miles that way or something I
know big old roadside yeah no I wasn't a
koala in the chat says I reckon your own
ethics if it helps yeah well going down
the way we came last yeah absolute and
field we've got a troublemaker a job
wait it's someone called Zack Rhian
youichi is that new hampered Shia weird
name - match
that match what is that it's not human
that's offensive that this guy it's a
positive a sea lion Tom Brown says
aesthetics where's Colchester Tom Brown
adds that Braintree is famous for its
wool cloth trade and silk manufacturing
so Thursday I'm doing the ass thing
again but coal Chester's they have grain
tree is just and me immediately Wes
sorry I just found a great place called
a Seng ttan can't argue with that
alright
she didn't there's a muffin geoguessr
those funny place names we should do
that next
yeah well I reckon like by the time we
do this one well we'll have time for
like one or two more something like that
yeah you kick what time what what time
is your big run like 20 and technically
we end in like 20 minutes but we won't
kick you off immediately so if we're in
the midway through one we could next
hour if that's all right this is oh look
what another acting turn what my mom's
got enough to deal with in a moment
because Karen this is an entire
intensify day that she's a pricks
nasty some great I can't hear him now oh
yeah oh wait cuz I haven't said anything
oh yeah it's slightly out of sync from
here pickles wait Isakov High Wycombe
Chelmsford Colchester high so Brentwood
Essex alright yeah well okay so what are
we looking for pan field
[Music]
which is by brain is a good to be
decided with my brain shielded the chat
the chat said it was your near brain
free okay well I'm looking at Colchester
on my map right now I can see Colchester
and then immediately to the west is
Braintree so I was right there we go
hello he's got the bumping out again so
just this green little house and plain
plain view
Daniel playing field yeah it's drop the
pin that'll be fine
Miller Road that'll be fine should we
just drop it and move on or do we want
to get the fall oh no again 25 you happy
without are you you know that we've won
25 canine
we got this we're almost there now
Oh bro oops mobs Ali says you listen
you're moving away from Essex go to pain
tree and move from there we did it
we're just this green we're not leaving
until you get 25 maybe this is finally
behind yeah yeah yeah a weed haul road
but none of these streets have names you
know who does have enables please no
names
ayo ayo girl tree who donate $20 thank
you thank you very much all right so
we're nearly there
where we kept us is this just cool look
the street the st st the street and hmm
I mean the problem is is not
a lot to go on around there think I
think it's a place called fat Fred's
my clothing line okay oh yeah so and
then here is just a little oh [ __ ] when
your cost doctor bearing off the road is
this a little that someone's house oh I
think we're playing a game where you can
go is that someone's house well we got
to a place the other day when we were
playing and all all of all of us are
being on holiday together to that place
we we lost our damn minds
we're coming too I think so yeah it's
going to come here I think very good I
think yeah if under 10 that'll be good
but let's see yes 4983 so our grand
scheme it's just been very good we have
less points enough for being not on the
actual bridge for God's sake how the
hell when I go across the when I go
across the bridge her name will always
be in my mind scar Schnepp Yorkshire
Dales National Park hello
just down from highway yocha dales
national park is pretty big lads I'm not
gonna lie
the region we've got a region now yeah
yeah laundry water treatment works
Scott beyond I didn't know I didn't know
we were still doing famous places you
got picture view you outside that side
Dean Brown says weight is very northern
yorkshire welcome to the party pal we
know perfectly of your fear so I found I
found your conflate good no I just found
weight by itself nothing animals half
way that PA says going to say to
something that's going into the park
based on the Sun this is good based on
the Sun good based on the Sun yeah Jay
Armstrong says Lowenthal a is just to
the side of Richmond Richmond Richmond
the rotational Jays Jays from your shoes
yeah yeah he's from around this America
driving I know you're going to Esau
flying should get our Lancashire so
where did they say just self Lowenthal a
is just to the side of Richmond it's to
the right kind of halfway up the tail up
to Dale's Dale's Lucy cross
[Laughter]
Oh Teesside International Airport
okay my aunt lives are on there - bring
her up alright Trudel he's going on
Rudy's tell us the truth obviously I
know it so well that I would refer to as
children she's like no way yeah kinda
Scotch corner though and absolutely
elite service station
she also says so to the west of Richmond
on the wobbly Green Bay is where you
want to look is that this to the west
over the west of Richmond
oh no hopefully God last wobbly thanks
wobbly all right this is wobbly that's
very wobbly yeah twelve alley spring
water low and sweet landscapes hello
okay wants waterworks oh okay Lucy
Kieran Marshall asks when you're aren't
leaves do you say true to Lou you know I
never okay Laurens right landscapes
we're here where
oh yeah I'm dinner
yeah well Richmond's where everyone
saying it's by a place called skeleton
skeleton I forgotten what we away we
sired Sears Tower
yeah I think anyway I think the work is
part of the landscape
no way yeah he said having a gander of
the map it doesn't look like what works
are shown on it so here not there wait
Oh River swale should be yeah that looks
like that looks like it all right yeah
let's do that
oh yeah that's great amazing amazing
well play a armstrong size 25 No yeah we
are yeah oh yeah wails wails wails wails
Oh outstanding
okay here we go this is a big road he
doesn't need any more slime soak it in
give me a give me a sign give me a sign
they know everything coffee
fitness sweet 12 I like to think what
that is so refers to that building the
background which is obviously the
hospital there yeah banal
they'll all be north so it'd be like
Colwyn Bay this was the last one of this
round yeah everyone the chairs behind
you thing I really like Fillmore we've
got this is my moment are h yl trill yes
525 chester Coney its north where they
know vowel if we're if we're vein of out
let no we asked to see right I'm trying
to write so right go right as north as
you possibly can yeah oh so a 55 is
right you can see Chester as well on
there or a 55 is bang right let me tell
you so you go wrong so you want to go on
the a 55 and then did you say it was
vein all like like f AE a Noel yeah yeah
please do this all in your thickest
Welsh accent slip into this vein know if
you okay so you want to go all the way
north and go to Colwyn Bay so on my
little dip there you've got a cold
invade and then honestly I think if you
go down the a 55 yes yes it's just calm
down
there's no time pressure we've got yeah
we do people in the chat scene don't if
it gaffe I cyst
what's the name of the hospital gaps
pride is on the line here nothing if he
was on our channel it would be a brand
empowerment ball I place you yeah this
hospital so far unnamed no just says
don't smoke
you shouldn't that's good advice Wow so
I fit so I know where real is so so if
you were on the a 55 yeah I'm just
following the a 55 now and I think I I
think I know what it is y'all man I do
miss it cause like you know legally
we're not allowed to go to Wales right
now yeah so legally I can't even go
there it's it's killing me it's killing
me
so if you so so if you zoom back out a
minute loose yeah but you just kept
going keep him now can you see me now I
[Laughter]
scream grab that for me loose no so see
what that golf club is there if you keep
on going up that things don't go there
but see that Golf Club I can I'm trying
to make it out but I can't quite so keep
going to the east like you know we go
you know you know it does that little
dimple thing so we need to fall over
basically too real and then I think you
know the big fat horse on England so
right
so you want to go right to the no no no
yeah we're going east we are I'm pretty
sure I'd be to a wedding in I'm pretty
sure I'll be to a wedding at banal vows
this is the a 55 yes oh hang on Pammy
that sign I think it had the junction
yeah didn't it it said well we want oh
no didn't it just said real yeah that's
okay so yeah it's hard for me because
I'm trying basically I've got liked
which I've got YouTube what I'm trying
to to work it out but I do think I know
where we are
and so right I mean the hospital would
be there so what you want to hear I
think the hospital can you go back to
where we were to begin in a minute let's
have a look at that
so we yeah because we're do we actually
start closer to the final caravan park
right this is a caravan park yeah yeah
wait a spa this hotel the industry are
in a caravan park yeah yeah so I think
that so real is just north of that I'm
basically like we're really close to
real so I think if we came down like to
the point where it's not even Road names
now we're on street names so it's that
little pad at caravan park
I have one Park
the cat though the caravan part we've
been looking at yeah
what's its next a little pad at caravan
park yeah if it is I know what Street
we're on someone in chat seems seems to
think that they've got it but I'm not
gonna say way is because I want to test
goats I'm not looking at that I'm just
looking out only thing I see is pure if
you think his mind's eye yeah it's
called misusing my heart but also given
the two different dates in which this
picture was taken
I like if I'm here it says manor house
but if I click in then it says yeah I
think different a hospital
I think the hospital is glad include
hospital oh oh that's big if true dice
big huge if true you'd if true where can
we get confirmation Colwyn Bay yeah so
hang on ok I'll direct you from there
right so what you want to do from Colwyn
Bay is go very East till you get to
thrill so that's it follow it all the
way across until you get a real which is
Kimmel Bay there you go you can see that
just north there yes yeah that's it
that's what you're looking for you see
the county house of mana so it's here oh
yes Anil Vout yeah yeah hospital as yeah
there we go go so just before this
little road so it's about here yeah oh
it's a little side road as well to help
us block that robotics for bikes Austin
Rover has been on the money so far
oh yeah it's good shelter oh yeah that
looks good you reckon anyone wait what's
the blue line is that water I think so
yes got to be right so can I just see
your map okay it's not really loaded
give me two seconds because I'm waiting
for it to load and you too bride I'm
trying not to look at the chat as well
you keep stupid keep going in keep going
and keep going every you going in wants
to feel Wales yeah I can feel it already
Ryan it Oh
three minutes to go how is this the last
one
everything so I know we've never had
Wales before if we open a minute okay so
so will we how far away from me
how far away we from final vowel so
final vowel is that's a little side road
and then side road okay so if oh that's
the caravan park though isn't it [ __ ]
the caravan park is so okay right okay
you're pretty close yeah so it is here
but it's just where do you want to yeah
cuz I so here so we literally are we
just on the road like coming down from
banal vows it's really hard for me to
see your screen basically so how so
where's that boosters but it's further
that Lucis positioners if you see the
street view now losses dropped as Joe
for that little tiny side we're breaking
to the right that's what that little
like that makes sense in there yeah yeah
itself it's like where is that
water behind us yeah I think well I
don't know where it's gonna be geoguessr
just yeah I think so it's alright okay
it's a little road yeah we're going for
it we're doing it yeah I think so I
think we've done well we've guys we've
got we've done well to find this I think
yeah and also we got we got to look
around the beautiful country all the way
yeah we took in the world and we were
gen Crips we've never hands Wales before
he's never come up as it no no not as
not as in like between you and me
because it comes up often I mean we said
we would eventually do Wales one day
there's a stream yeah
again we have got one person Austin
Rover who is also following along and
correctly saying what part Wales were in
he says he thinks it's slightly up
slightly up but yeah I guess like the
water thing is the only thing I throw me
off is a lot yeah blues we can't see
that I said I think we yeah I think
we're good yeah yeah let's do it
as long as we get five grand we'll be
fine definitely I'm gonna hit it in
three two one three metres oh three
Mears oh that's great well done we've
got a five five grands
that that's an amazing team fo days you
couldn't have written that you couldn't
have written that I can with them well
every single one
yeah shocker any no no nothing too far
and to end the stream as well are whales
god yeah that's pretty good that's
pretty like coming home it's like no we
know that is because it does feel like
coming home actually yeah home for over
here we also got a ten dollar donation
from Matt Hawking again yes thank you
thank you
oh that was amazing I would have liked
gap Beth workman ever name another one
John oh yeah he's a legend chess he says
nicely done oh thank you chastity I miss
you there we go that was good I was
happy that I was happy goodbye so much
yeah thanks for having us on but yet but
before we go there we got a little
surprise cuz Tom it was your birthday
this week was in there it was yeah
what's going on there we we got you some
some birthday cake
ah all the way all the way some I go to
well cheesecake I got you and the mr.
Kipling's baked well slice slice
alright I'm gonna do them as well can I
blow him out yeah I'm gonna blow on 3
ready 1 2 3
well done you guys have been amazing you
raise so much money as well hopefully
lots of people be being good and in the
chat and raising money for us as well so
that's lovely well done everyone
we've had good eggs amazing like all the
guests that we've had on everyone who's
watched and been in the chair
donated and it's been really great and
this is technically like the last
charity proper stream tomorrow we're
doing a kind of round up final like
we're doing after dark podcast live the
final big charity one I'm glad we got to
end it on a bang yeah yes without good
friends miss very deep I know that's
amazing yeah I'm so glad that we had
this one be the mean the last one before
our kind of wind down oh thank you Wales
and in Wales like whatever you do just
end on wailing yes thank you again
everyone we'll see you tomorrow for a
game swap after dog live to kind of
round off play for all thank you to
everyone we'll see you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]